droht uns eine pleitewelle wenn die
insolvenzregeln dann wieder gelten die
droht nicht nur die wird kommen
hubertus heil hat natürlich recht dass
das kurzarbeitergeld einen riesen
erfolgsmodell ist die welt beneidet uns
darum
zur wahrheit gehört aber auch dass
dieses jahr aufgelaufen das muss man
sich mal vorstellen
die weniger insolvenzen haben als im
letzten jahr
ohne corona das hängt mit den umstand
zusammen dass firmen die nicht
zahlungsfähig sind bis vor kurzem keine
insolvenz anmelden mussten
selbst firmen die überschuldet sind
müssen jetzt keine insolvenz anmelden
sondern erst ab dem 11 kommenden jahres
das heißt wir werden im ersten quartal
6000 7000 8000 insolvenzen er leben im
maschinenbau im automobilbereich aber
wahrscheinlich auch veranstaltungs
hotelbereich ich will ja nicht ins
detail gehen nur man muss diese wahrheit
auch aussprechen weil wenn wir jetzt
diesen insolvenzgrund überschuldung und
zahlungsunfähigkeit immer weiter
aussetzen dann verschlimmert gehe ja das
problem weil es gibt beispielsweise
zulieferer die offene rechnung haben mit
anderen firmen
die würden wir ja dann mit in den
abgrund ziehen deswegen müssen die uns
ehrlich machen und die insolvenzen
werden kommen ja aber dieses land ist
stark genug um das zu überstehen